[Music]
just hundred and thirty three days to go
until you become the ultimate jury and
you make the ultimate decision Biden
seems content the campaign almost well
solely alone is basement bunker
indefinitely
all right here with reaction to this
much more Dallas Mavericks owner shark
tank I love the show I think it's an
awesome show I love entrepreneurial ISM
and Mark Cuban is back with us alright
so you and I have talked about Trump
you've been on the program now a couple
of times now I want to talk to you about
Biden first question do you believe that
he has the strength the stamina the
mental acuity the alertness to be taking
on what is the toughest job in the world
being the President of the United States
doing you in your heart believe he does
high percent absolutely no question
about it okay Donald Trump doesn't want
to run a country he wants to run a
campaign Joe Biden actually wants to run
a country okay that's you give me a
bumper sticker I'm just that you've told
me how you feel about Trump and how what
you like and dislike you were honest you
said he did a lot of good things too now
here's my next question Joe Martin has
been on the political scene for 50 years
now after Ferguson Baltimore Cambridge
and a lot of incidents he didn't put in
police reforms Donald Trump did that he
was talking about predators in 94 Donald
Trump is the one that did criminal
justice and prison reform Donald Trump
did Opportunity Zones not Joe or Barack
Donald Trump gave us record low after
record low unemployment for every
minority group in the country not Joe
and not Barack and my question is they
eat that's all fact that's all fashion
you give me the bumper stickers okay but
look that's better but you can say the
exact same thing about every single
Republican senator right this guy
they're not running for president I'm
asking you this just a minute Joe's been
in office fifty women fifty years he was
vice president for eight years Trump did
that not Joe so tell me what Joe tell me
well here's the question tell me what
Joe has done that you're proud of the
who qualifies him to be President
after 50 years it wasn't my senator
della Delaware I don't know but this
probably vice president Shawn Shawn it
was a problem for all senators the
question you were asked when you vote
for somebody is one of these president
he was vice president in eight years
what did he do he had eight years okay
well let's say he was a big part of
Obamacare the ACA here we are Shawn
you've got millions if not tens of
millions of people losing their
employers insurance Donald Trump has not
said a word
and that's year was nothing Shawn not
only is he not said a word about health
care he's looking to end the ACA with no
replacement okay let me ask you that
stuff right is it important I really
want an answer so in eight years
the obama-biden record is 13 million
more Americans on food stamps 8 million
warm poverty the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s and
Donald Trump's record pre corona record
low unemployment African Americans fact
Hispanic Americans fact Asian Americans
youth unemployment women in the
workplace so he's only better hoopa's
less than four years okay obama and
biden they took over after the last
really back and grew the economy
continuously but when they had a problem
to solve which was the Great Recession
12 years ago they solved it now where
are we now we are not solving it we've
had bumps and that's a beautiful thing
we're going in the right track mark we
just had two and a half million new jobs
and a record retail sales in the history
of the country
yes not all Trump did that not Biden in
the base like I explained it to my kids
when your bank account goes from $10 to
$1 and then all of a sudden it goes to
two you can say you doubled your bank
account but you're still down yeah
but they predicted nine and a half
million jobs lost we gave two and a half
million now I didn't think that would
happen till August I never thought I
never saw 18% increase in retail sales
did you know and that comes back to what
you said about
for Norse they are the backbone of this
country and I know the German people are
I know Joe Biden believes in
entrepreneurship because I went to a
White House event that he spoke about on
you spoke about it and talk come on what
are you doing eight years as vice
president tell me the biggest
accomplishment in eight years tell me
the biggest one elephant what is easily
their biggest accomplishment and it's
unfortunate that they're trying to
dismantle it and I'll also say number
two and this is how I know Joe I'll go
back to what I just said
the one event I went for entrepreneurs
in the White House that Joe Biden put on
and spoke about his support for
entrepreneurship is one more event than
done for profit ever thrown for
entrepreneurs on the White House or
anywhere else all right so if you were
to go into voting by listen I I kind of
admire you cuz you got you know I love
your outspoken I love that you like
entrepreneurs I think your politics and
I think your politics and nuts but I you
know you having a hard time defending
biting his record here's what I'm gonna
challenge you I'm gonna give you time to
do your research I'm gonna fight you
back on the show and you tell me the
great record of Joe Biden in the last 50
years all right is that a fair deal keep
saying that he was vice president come
up with the short for the common cold
as a senator Donald Trump cured cancer
people would hate him the guys never had
if nobody's ever done record after
record after record I thank you Mark
Cuban